♪ ♪
>> Katie: TRUMP TAKING ON
TWITTER, THE PRESIDENT
THREATENING TO REGULATE OR CLOSE
DOWN SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
AFTER TWITTER STARTED
FACT-CHECKING HIS TWEETS.
TRUMP ACCUSING THEM OF SILENCING
CONSERVATIVES AND TRYING TO
INTERFERE WITH THE 2020
ELECTION.
TWITTER ADDED A WARNING LABEL TO
HIS TWEETS ABOUT MAIL-IN BALLOTS
AND VOTER FRAUD.
THIS IS A WHOLE CAN OF WORMS.
TWITTER IS USING CNN AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AS THEIR
FACT-CHECKERS.
>> Greg: THINK ABOUT IT, WHAT
IS EASIER.
THROW AWAY A BAG OF OATS.
THE FACT-CHECKING THING, WAY TO
TACKLE MISINFORMATION WHICH
WOULD BE GOOD IF THERE WAS A
BALLOTS AND MISINFORMATION BUT
WE KNOW FROM RESEARCH THAT THE
NEWS MEDIA IS ABOUT 90% LIBERAL.
THE RIGHT GENERALLY IS OVER
POLICED DAILY COMPARED TO THE
LEFT.
IT IS LIKE A HIGHWAY WHERE ONLY
THE RED CARS GET PULLED OVER
WHILE THE BLUE CARS KEEP GOING.
THAT’S HOW WE POLICE
MISINFORMATION.
I THINK THIS KIND OF
FACT-CHECKING IS AN EXAMPLE.
IT WILL JUST EXTEND THE PRACTICE
OF GOING AFTER THINGS THAT ARE
SAID BY TRUMP OR SAID BY
CONSERVATIVE OUTFITS.
IMAGINE IF YOU TRIED TO
FACT-CHECK EVERYTHING SET
AGAINST TRUMP, FROM THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION TO THE ACCUSATIONS OF
RACISM TO THE 25TH AMENDMENT
THAT WENT ON FOR A COUPLE MONTHS
THEN YOU HAVE THE BLOOD LIBEL OF
THE CORONAVIRUS AND WHAT YOU
HAVE CERTAIN PEOPLE ON MSNBC
SAYING HE’S GOT 100,000 DEATHS
ON HIS HANDS.
IT’S IMPOSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY
FACT-CHECK THE IMMENSITY OF
THESE CLAIMS AGAINST TRUMP.
YOU KNOW THAT IT’S ONLY GOING TO
WORK ONE WAY.
THEY ARE GOING TO PULL OVER THE
RED CARS IN THE BLUE CARS DRIVE
BY.
>> Katie: DANA, FOR A WHILE
NOW, BIG SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
LIKE TWITTER AND FACEBOOK HAVE
BEEN THREATENED WITH REGULATION.
THEY CLAIM THEY ARE JUST A
PUBLIC PLATFORM BUT THEN THEY DO
THINGS LIKE EDIT CONTENT, BAN
CONTENT, IN THIS CASE FACT JACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEETS.
LET’S GET A SNEAK PEEK AT YOUR
INTERVIEW WITH MARK ZUCKERBERG.
>> Dana: TWITTER DECIDED TO
FACT-CHECK ONE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEETS.
I WONDER IF YOU THINK TWITTER
MAY HAVE MADE A WRONG DECISION.
SPEAK WE HAVE A DIFFERENT POLICY
THAN TWITTER ON THIS.
I BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT FACEBOOK
SHOULDN’T BE THE ARBITER OF
TRUTH OF EVERYTHING PEOPLE SAY
ONLINE.
I THINK IN GENERAL, PRIVATE
COMPANIES PROBABLY, SPECIALLY
THESE PLATFORM COMPANY SHOULDN’T
BE IN THE POSITION OF DOING THAT
THAT.
>> Dana: THAT’S A POLICY THAT
THE FACEBOOK TEAM PUT IN PLACE
LAST OCTOBER AROUND THE TIME
THAT I FIRST INTERVIEWED HIM.
THE UPROAR FROM THE LEFT HAS
NEVER LET UP AGAINST FACEBOOK ON
THIS.
THEY WANT HIM TO BE POLICING
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEETS BUT NOT
THEIR OWN.
IT’S DONE SOMETHING PRETTY
INTERESTING TO WATCH.
THEY HAVE STUCK TO THEIR GUNS.
I FURTHER ASKED, WHAT WOULD BE
THE LINE?
IS THERE A LINE THEY WOULD
CROSS?
AND HE WAS CLEAR, THEY LOOK AT
THE SUPREME COURT RULING IN
TERMS OF FREE SPEECH AND IF IT
DOESN’T HAVE IMMINENT HARM TO
SOMEBODY OR MISINFORMATION THAT
WOULD HURT SOMEBODY, THEN WHEN
IT COMES TO POLITICAL SPEECH
THEY’RE GOING TO BE HANDS-OFF.
I THINK THAT’S PROBABLY THE
RIGHT DECISION.
IF I WAS SITTING THERE, I DON’T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT I WOULD DO.
I THINK THAT’S THE RIGHT THING.
FREE SPEECH IS SOMETHING THAT
AMERICANS CHERISH.
AMERICAN COMPANY SHOULD CHERISH.
THERE WAS NO NEED FOR TWITTER TO
GET INVOLVED.
WHY FACT-CHECK THAT PARTICULAR
TWEET?
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF TWEETS YOU
COULD CHOOSE BUT THEY CHOSE THE
MAIL-IN VOTING.
THERE’S CONTROVERSY ABOUT
THERE ARE STATISTICS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT TOOK SEATTLE ABOUT TEN YEARS
TO GET IT RIGHT.
THERE WAS A GREAT PIECE ON IT
EXPLAINING IT’S PRETTY GOOD NOW
BUT IT TOOK TEN YEARS FOR THEM
TO GET IT TO BE GOOD.
I THINK THERE IS ROOM FOR
DEBATE.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY TWITTER
DECIDED TO STEP IN ON THAT
PARTICULAR TWEET YESTERDAY, WHEN
THERE WAS PLENTY OF OTHER
INCLUDING ONE YESTERDAY THEY
COULD’VE TAKEN ACTION ON.
>> Katie: SHOULDN’T THEY BE
FACT-CHECKING, I DON’T KNOW,
MEMBERS OF THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY WHO ARE LIES ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS ON TWITTER?
THEY AREN’T DOING THAT.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TOO MUCH MONEY IN CHINA.
WHY DON’T THEY FACT-CHECK PENCIL
NECK?
HE IS BY LYING ABOUT CLOSURE FOR
THREE YEARS.
I WOULD PUT A FACT-CHECK BEHIND
ANY OF THOSE TWEETS.
I KNOW WHY THEY CHOSE THIS.
IT IS THE ONLY WAY THEY ARE
GOING TO BEAT TRUMP, BALLOT
HARVESTING.
IT’S NOT EVEN A FACT-CHECK,
KATIE.
IT IS SPIN.
I HAVE SHEETS OF PAPER HERE OF
REPORTS THAT I FOUND ON TWITTER
THAT SAY THAT THERE’S A LOT OF
ABUSE WITH MAIL BALLOTS.
IT’S FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
AP, CBS.
THESE ARE IN FACT-CHECKERS.
IT’S LIKE THE DEMOCRAT STATE OF
THE UNION REBUTTAL AND THEY
DON’T UNDERSTAND HOW WEAK IT
MAKES THE LEFT LOOK.
BECAUSE BIDEN CAN’T TAKE THEM
OUT.
THE MEDIA CAN’T TAKE THEM OUT.
NOW THEY ARE ASKING BIG TECH FOR
HELP?
YOU CAN’T DO THIS ON YOUR OWN?
WHY CAN’T BIDEN RETWEET TRUMP
AND SAY THIS OR THAT?
THAT’S HIS JOB.
THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT THE GUY
IN CHARGE OF ENFORCING THE RULES
ON TWITTER OR SOME LEFT-WING
HACK THAT CALLED THE TRUMP FOLKS
NAZIS.
THE WHOLE THING IS SO COOKED UP.
IT’S ALMOST HELPING THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE IT MAKES HIM,
AGAIN, LOOK LIKE HE’S NOT
EVERYBODY AGAINST HIM.
TWITTER, THE FBI, THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
HE’S GOING TO SHOVE IT RIGHT
BACK IN THEIR FACE IN NOVEMBER.
>> Katie: SO DONNA.
THOSE ARGUMENTS.
>> Donna: JESSE, I WISH I
COULD SEND YOU SOME TISSUES BUT
I’D HAVE TO BE 6 FEET FROM YOU.
>> Jesse: I’M NOT WHINING.
YOU’RE THE ONE WHO’S WHINING.
COMPLAINING.
>> Donna: THE SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> Jesse: IF BIDEN WAS A REAL
CONTENDER --
STUFF IT RIGHT DOWN TRUMP’S
THROAT BUT HE NEEDS
SILICON VALLEY TO HELP THEM OUT.
>> Donna: YOU’RE TALKING OVER
ME BECAUSE YOU’RE TALKING
NONSENSE.
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THE INFORMATION, THE PRESIDENT’S
TWEETS SHOULD HAVE BEEN DELETED.
I WOULD HAVE DELETED THE
PRESIDENT’S TWEETS.
YOU KNOW WHY?
IT’S A BALD-FACED LIE.
IT’S REPUBLICANS WHO USE
ABSENTEE BALLOTS TO GET OUT
THERE VOTE.
THAT’S TRADITIONALLY BEEN THE
WAY THAT REPUBLICANS HAVE ALWAYS
MOTIVATED THEIR VOTERS.
GO AHEAD AND VOTE EARLY.
I THINK THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM COMPANY SHOULD REGULATE
THEMSELVES AND THEY SHOULD MAKE
SURE THAT THESE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THE ONE THE PRESIDENT
PUT OUT ABOUT JOE SCARBOROUGH,
IT SHOULD BE DELETED.
THE LIES NEED TO STOP.
THERE IS NO FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO LIE.
PERIOD.
>> Katie: AND WITH THAT, WE
WILL MOVE ON.
>> Dana: ACTUALLY YOU CAN.
>> Donna: THERE’S NO
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO LIVE.
THERE IS NO FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO LIVE.
GO AHEAD AND LIE.
>> Greg: I CAN SAY I’M 6 FEET
TALL.
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE ME
ARRESTED?
>> Donna: NO.
>> Greg: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
POLITICIANS, DONNA?
IF YOU COULDN’T LIE, YOU’D HAVE